[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with columnist
carol malone and political editor of the
liverpool echo liam thought that they'll
be with us from now until uh just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages now
after today's announcements in the
commons the eyes headline is every home
to get 400 pounds cut in energy bills
as the metro puts it rishi to the rescue
at last
the express reads rishi's 1200 pounds
boost for 8 million
and the telegraph leads with mr sunak's
claim that the tories are now a party of
big spending and generosity
similarly the male calls the plan a
splurge
but the guardian says mr sunak finally
bowed to months of pressure over the
cost of living crisis finally announcing
a package of support during a bruising
week for the government
the time says the tories are split on
the tax and spending bonanza
while the financial times says north sea
oil and gas operators think the windfall
tax is a multi-year assault on their
profits that will drive away investors
and cut production
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by congress
carol malone and the political editor of
the liverpool echo liam thorpe welcome
to you both let's start with the eye
front page uh every home to get that 400
pounds cut in energy bills uh carol
let's start with you good news all round
oh good yeah i think it's i think it's
great it's much more it's a much more
generous packet package than we
originally thought this means that 28
million people in england scotland and
wales are going to get this this 400
quid and it means that something is like
8 million people are going to get 650
pounds which is going to be of an
enormous help to people um i think there
was a you know there was a real panic
this week um as you know we're hearing
that that you know the energy cap is
going to go to 2800 pounds so this is i
mean i think this is great news i mean i
you know i'm watching social media and
i'm listening to to the left and a lot
of people are saying it isn't enough but
i mean i think it's an enormous amount
at this time um you know there are there
are lots of accusations about um you
know issues splurging this money this is
effectively another budget but he didn't
have a lot of choice i mean the left are
complaining that he's stolen their idea
but it's no it's not an original idea it
was maggie thatcher did it as did golden
brown so it's not an original thing to
do but of course there are worries about
this windfall tax you know it depends
what it means for us um you know they're
say they're saying it's going to affect
their profits which which is true it is
but you know in the first quarter of
this year i think it was shell made 9.3
billion and exxon made 8.3 billion in
the first three months and that's
threefold what they normally make and
that's i'm glad we're taking some of
that from them but i think people must
be aware of what it might mean for us in
the sense that it's likely to affect
pensions because the the big oil
companies might cut or hear or cut or
not or completely slash their dividends
which that would affect pensioners and
it will also affect savers i mean it's
not it's not a free ride it's not just
punishing the energy companies it may
well affect us as well so it's you know
it's it's
the package is good um but but the
windfall tax who knows yeah how that's
gonna work out
uh liam do you agree with carol that it
is good news this uh 15 billion pounds
to ease the cost of living crisis we'll
look at the the metro and uh they're
claiming that uh rishi sunak has come to
the rescue at last
yeah i would sort of emphasize the at
last bit because it's it's taken him
long enough i think it was about five
months ago that the label were first
proposing the windfall attacks and
obviously the liberal democrats were
were fully behind it as well um yes i
think broadly is is good news i think
it's as carol says it's more than i
think we were expecting in fact i think
it's a little bit of a problem for labor
now because the overall package
you know it kind of dwarfs what what
they were proposing they were looking at
raised about two billion so they've now
got to go back and think what they're
going to do to to make themselves look
like they're they're more on the side of
hard-pressed people than than the tories
which is an interesting position to be
in um i think the most important thing
here is that it is broadly um going to
the the people who are in the most
difficult positions and that's something
that many people have been calling for
for a long time you know that money is
is going out
from these these big companies that are
making uh incredible unbelievable
amounts of money that they don't know
what to do with frankly and it is being
more targeted with this package towards
people with disabilities people on
lowest incomes and pensioners and that's
exactly right that's what should be
happening
it's not perfect of course and there are
there are some issues for example that
there is a strong argument to say that
the the the kind of blunt instrument of
giving everybody 400 quid doesn't quite
work especially when we find out that it
does
uh it means that 400 for each house so
if you've got multiple homes you get
that amount for each house i think mr
sunic has already said that he's gonna
have to donate some back to charity
because of how many homes he's got but
but
overall i would say it's it's an
important package from the chancellor
and it's it was badly needed
obviously it has it has taken some time
to get to this point and yes i would
would argue that it is uh taking
labour's idea but it has then taken it
on a bit as well so um i i wasn't
expecting this much so i think it's
broadly good news yeah yeah uh a
windfall tax by any other name though
that that wasn't mentioned at all it's
the temporary targeted energy profits
levy that uh catchy name carol um let's
look at the the guardian talking about
the 15 billion package that that has
been unveiled and we um we read that the
institute for fiscal studies they're
describing it as a genuinely big package
of support
yeah i think it was paul johnson today
who said his quote was it's a big
expensive package for sunak and he said
in conjunction with tax rises already in
place it's hugely redistributive um
from the highest what he's saying is
it's taking from the high owners to give
to the poor owners he was very critical
um about rasheed not cutting taxes but
he thinks that the package
broadly is the right thing to do so i
mean it's a thumbs up from there it's a
thumbs up from most people you know as
liam said this was very badly needed it
probably took longer than it should have
but you know it's here now and it kind
of you know when i hear the left sniping
today when i hear people like rachel
reeves in the comments sniping today
saying he pinched her idea well you know
rachel reeves does not invent the idea
of a windfall tech i'm sorry and many
many more um
some more important people than her have
done it before but anyway she it's it's
silly as labour to snipe because as liam
says they are now going to have to work
harder to be the party who looks after
the working classes so it but it just
makes them look a bit silly now to
attack him in this way
uh liam very quickly carol saying that
everybody's uh happy all round but not
the the energy groups as we read in the
financial times
no no well obviously not um
they're not not happy enough with the
the the money that they were making that
they're describing some of the north sea
um uh oil and gas giants are describing
it as a multi-year tax and their
argument is is i just don't agree that
at all that it's gonna it's gonna stop
it in investment i think they know
there's still an awful lot of money that
that they're going to be making and
their shareholders are going to be
making from people but for too long and
and certainly in more recent times
hard-pressed people have been have been
the ones paying for this and we've been
we've been and they have no choice
people have no choice but to try and
heat their homes to try and use energy
and these guys have been making enormous
profits so something had to be done now
i'm personally in favor of nationalizing
the the energy companies but this is
this is something
to start with anyway liam and cary must
leave it there we're going to take a
break and coming up the daily telegraph
references chancellor rishi sunak saying
the conservatives are now the party of
big spending
[Music]
if you are watching the press preview
still with me congress carol malone and
the political editor of the liverpool
echo liam thorpe to you first off in
this section carol let's have a look at
the daily telegraph and their story
there that the conservatives are now
boasting being the party of a big
spendings according to rishi sunak
yeah i mean they're saying the telegraph
is quoting the figure of 21 billion as a
package of support and also tsunamis vow
to increase universal credit next year
and state pensions and that's and that's
in line with inflation which could
possibly cost another 15 billion pounds
so yes they are the the party of big
spending now and it's it's interesting
that that a lot of tories are furious
with them today because they're saying
that the way to
you know to to stimulate growth is to
cut taxes and and yet he seems dead set
against them has done you know from the
off he does not want to he's increasing
taxes which is what the institute of
fiscal studies accused him of today
although sunak said yesterday he was
actually cutting taxes he cleared taxes
he clearly isn't and but yes i mean that
it is becoming the part of big spending
and it's going to be a problem for
labour on how to hit them in this so
yeah
um just because of time we want to move
on to another story uh liam and this is
uh being covered
in the metro um one of our reporters
mark stone cornered ted cruz over the
most recent shootings in america at
school shootings in america and uh he he
got a very surprising response
yeah first of all i just wanted to give
maximum credit to mark stone uh for the
way he approached this he sort of lured
ted cruz in with it with a you know a a
sort of soft start to the interview
naturally paying tribute to what what's
happened and then he he cornered him on
this very key question which ted cruz
just cannot answer which is why is this
happening in america and it's not
happening in other countries and the
reason for that is because of their
the republican party blocking basic
background checks on on and basic gun
controls and they have done that you
know
it was ten years ago
afraid we have actually run out of time
thank you so much